for those just joining your joining at a
good time
starting in less than 30 seconds it's uh
it's a johner arena it's basically the
reddit the reddit our chess
arena yeah hello to so many people roof
was first and tiny semis
no it's for the sub eight seven six
yeah I can't say hello to everyone but
people can use the hello commander
okay this is gonna be three hours of ten
of the child playing variants only oh
let's play a London and I think I'll I
will bezerk most games variants only I
looked up is like 2700 and blitz so
strong player I try and stay focused
yeah c5 is a topical move these days I
think d5 I could also take I could also
play e5 I don't try and be just solid
and safe take and maybe I'll even Castle
kingside play like Bishop Bishop c4
makes some sense
expecting queen a5 at some points yeah
so takes and then Bishop III I'm just
trying to hold my own
hello two more people okay I'm gonna try
not to get too distracted by the chat
it's gonna be a lot of chess today you
can throw in each three make some sense
yeah just preventing Bishop g4 or Knight
g4 in some cases it's another Sun watch
on the streams goat thank you
okay ob5 interesting
I could play Bishop I'm Bishop e3 Queen
h5g for a my trapping a queen no I'm not
G for hangs upon mmm kind of feels close
to so good before it's ready five
starting before Thank You Lou to Gigi
what to do there should be three queen
h5 could just buy a three yeah slow and
steady probably should not have taken
that long yeah I wanted to do this but
there's a pin so Bishop g4 was possible
like g4 right away
[Music]
here's a crazy idea oh it's so crazy no
it doesn't work I was thinking Bishop
III and Queen h5 King II - Oh what to do
complete g4 right away
it's kind of crazy I think I won't do it
because I'm threatening now Bishop III
chopping Queen and for the time being
there's there's this but then I have a
pin hey welcome back banana
okay so Bishop III is the main threat I
mean but I could play Queen b6 and then
I'll probably end up castling okay let's
take from Bishop III could play f3 yeah
like f3 well there's no Brook tea in
immediately the structure is pretty
solid
the pawn blocks a bishop some 95 ideas
never mind
let's castle
okay let's uh move let's play rook or d1
rook e8 I just take it rook c8 I could
play Queen d6 play 92 some g5 move to
hmm
not too much time
texts okay I think I'll go with this I
mean black could take play Bishop f8
never up d2 we trade and Queenie eights
okay
I still want to play g5 but it doesn't
quite work play Bishop b6 maybe oh no
Brooke c6 was coming hmm okay I might
have to just change my mind there are
too many scary rook moves the Queen
probably belongs enough to if ever
before I can take 94 and these squares
are kind of nice it's like we enough -
yeah just preparing kind of slow
build-up I don't think that scares me
oh I was probably good timing takes
takes takes I could play 94 yeah I had
mentioned this earlier I don't know why
that took me so long these squares who
can take Wow so you playing might be six
let's hold off for now like 1 G 2 so I
have two minors for Rick and two pawns
it's still threats of 96 I don't really
want to take with pawn but to keep my
rook back you for expected efore Rick f1
rook f1 anyway
now the Queen's tied down to the pawn
yeah there's some pressure with my
bishop and I see five ideas like 95 to
e4 and then g5 eventually it's all about
getting in g5 there's some nice weak
squares to exploit yeah the Queen wants
to come here to prevent 94 but then I
win the pawn let's do this you had g5
incoming and Knight f6 will be super
nice takes takes I mean it should just
be winning while King f8 so I could take
500c - that's okay though
I have to stay focused it's so
complicated
and play this move cementing the bishop
a 94 97 check I'm looking for like
mating ideas a threatening Bishop c5 now
and 9 of 6 still on the horizon I got
out of the pin which i think is
important
I could probably draw but position looks
really good it looks a bit stuck
actually okay let's take finding f7 now
let's move finding work - Yates I was a
little bit risky still threatening work
- Yates
let's just take check check
meet incoming let's go okay that was
intense
I got low on time kind of oh I was very
intense I was a nice scheme though had
to keep my composure
it got tricky it and there the time
situation that was a good start one
person already has two buzzer Queens hmm
three berserk wins that's crazy
that's scary - hey meets COO I only have
this four thanks for the bits Oh play a
time on us yeah we'll probably see at
least one time on of the stream so yeah
it's it's a long tournament I mean
they're 10 minutes in taking a while for
a gig to start there we go
oh I'm playing I'm playing first place I
don't know if I should bezerk any any
information
Oh bullets I shouldn't bezerk if my
phone's not working
okay okay oh I thought I'd be zerk by
didn't it made the sound but I guess
that was bad timing
okay that's funny
let's play for ya a queen a5 so e5 is
coming late Bishop d2 actually kind of
looks normal
Wow
so pond is not scared of discoveries I
mean 95 is playable but then queen d8
you'll just play e4 before takes takes
there's Queen before it's Snow Queen
before I have an IP five okay let's do
this
I see seven okay so we're gonna have
some kind of old Indian set up one let's
play age three the bishop will come back
to e3 almost likely and then there's
some interesting Queen move yeah like
queen bee one Queen e2 idea to hit f7
now for key seven I'll have like this
idea maybe not h5 to f5 there's never g6
because Knight takes g6 and this is
already looking nice this is a major
threats yeah there's a nice kind of
peace harmony yeah that's right need to
take with check so I mean there's no d5
even surprise my pawns not resigning
yeah let's take with check take with
checking yeah I'm gonna take this thing
95 can take and simplify and rookie
three coming never mind
oh let's play rook d1 just watching out
for us
f2
would have been nice to get the buzzer
keen points about what to do
rook to e3 is a move number of d3 I
could also just take yeah let's just
take never up d3 also Queen e6 got so
many options I'll start with this
dreaming of this manoeuvre okay rook g3
rook f3 might be the safest just worry
free move and now this move Knight takes
e4 takes takes all seems good takes
takes and then take something takes
meanwhile I want to just get the I'll
post the knife on f5 I have c3 here
which I think just traps a bishop just
making sure
yeah and the rooks still defense of if
takes after I just take back okay that
was nice so I'm trying to be competitive
I had it in mind to berserk every game
but I guess I missed my opportunity
opportunity there
yeah sorry if I'm missing comments and
questions and the chats but hopefully if
there's questions other people can
answer oh if you were not a chess
/youtube professional
what will your profession be no I'm
playing coach John probably something in
like digital marketing photography
graphic design web development
okay nighty-night f3 to play a walrus
what to play I'll just stick with my
main Robert or play d5 yeah we'll have a
English ready type thing okay we have
the Catalan I'll play okay Bishop do you
choose a main move I'll play Bishop
before Bishop d2 Zameen no but I
opponents already taking some time which
is nice what camera do I have a camera I
use for photography it's a sony a7r Mark
3 it's a nice camera I got it right
before the World Championship match in
London okay Queen takes you'd have had
this position once before in the
tournament game and I won really quickly
I'm trying to remember here I just
Castle if Queen takes e4 I have b5 which
is a cool idea yeah and it solves all of
the issues with this bishop and it's not
even a pawn sacrifice if Queen takes b5
I work be a and an almond back b2
now I'll get some nice bishops
this bishop either comes to be seven or
a six there's always Queen b6 ideas Oh
Harry Jasper loves that camera yeah I
have I have two lenses I have 85 prime
one no it's a yeah it's a 1.8 a queen f4
what is this play Bishop e7 shouldn't
take too much time here I also have the
the G master was at 16 to 36 or 35 it's
a great lens it was an investment though
okay let's stay focused Queen b6
probably yeah he for is usually met by a
six and I think the the main setup is
just rooks on DNC eight this night
sometimes can find a home on g6 in this
case to harass the Queen if the knight
comes to g6 the Queen's almost trapped
like queen g v h6 it takes some time
though
[Music]
before interesting for the queen defense
that's a slightly annoying move and
Bishop III is coming next
Bishop III I could play Bishop d6
actually let's play Bishop e6 is gaining
time and then what to do probably this
move Bishop III I'm looking at this move
attacking the knight then threatening
ninety five as well I might want to
include rookie HS just defend the bishop
to prepare ninety four a four
interesting so I could play Knight e5
right away why not if you want to see my
photography I think I have a flicker
typing exclamation point flicker or
exclamation point Instagram in the chat
people watching in the future on YouTube
can't do that though you'll have to have
to click the links in my video
description
okay so we're trading
I probably trade some more ah there's a
heat I'll be right back
it's hot enough in this room okay so I'm
still down three minutes but phones
really taking time so and the thing
about the trade is now our B ponds are
both kind of weak I think I might just
have 95 as a threat but should be three
okay so queen c6 I'm hitting the night
also ideas was like 95 and I can't
really move anywhere great it can't move
back here cuz things broke might be
expecting I guess that's a reasonable
move 95 doesn't work because white just
takes it does that work here takes takes
takes takes it's playable
take stick stick sticks
I'm getting confused but I think it's
playable so here it takes I take here
has to take here and then I take here
and lights hanging there's no 97 it
might be 6 or 97 rook c8 it takes it's
just a big trade let's do it
hope I'm not missing anything
yeah that's it's important than my my
bishop covers a 7 I guess 97 is expected
here to counter-attack the rook oh wait
and I see 7 I just play here I'm just
gonna be up the exchange as I'm
temporarily up the exchange because I
won the UM I won the rook on c6 like
white would like to do something about
this night and then take the bishop but
I don't think there's much time yeah
when I initially calculated this I just
saw nighty-night c7 I moved my bishop
and I lose my rook
I can use my rook to counter-attack the
night I did not see the the Magnus
banter blitz today I saw some tweet
about it something about him getting
food delivery
ya know I can feel my opponent suffering
here it's like there's there's no
undoing the past I'm wondering if White
had anything better
I guess there's Knight takes c6 here
it's the best move and I'll have to
convert up the exchange calculating here
here probably pawn takes which I don't
know boy what White's gonna take with
the knight takes I'm happy to trade the
bishop if pawn takes it's a bit damaging
to the structure I'm thinking about
taking Knight here to here or even
there's rook c4 in some position don't
want to get my bishop away the hell
let's play Knight f6 this could be a
nice square allowing Bishop c5 but then
rook to e8
mm-hmm I could probably just take and
rook c6 I do want to get my my knight to
kind of remove this bishop
so probably h6 Knight e4 and then rook
c4
yeah the knight was trying to do damage
but it's going to have to go back where
it came from
cause we're up T to move to some points
so the player I be the still in first I
mean having a nice buzz irking strategy
let's go 494 Bishop III expected oh
there's my e5 coming at some points
could be annoying and 95 have to play
rook c8 and Bishop b6 so I can get some
initiative I don't think it's too
harmful but slightly annoying
I can play rook d5 here even rook c4
yeah just going after the pawn if rook
e1 I have Knight see 395 I just oh I
can't take it cuz this month okay
yeah let's take I think 95 was another
move to go for unleashing my rook I have
the past pass beep on if here I have 95
95 should be simple could throw in some
rook check but no need
yeah lights gonna have two sets of
double pawns
[Music]
expecting rugby 7 takes takes rakia King
F to work b3
and I'll win the pond while probably
holding on to the spawn or I'll just win
both ponds
mm-hmm that's a reasonable move I go
take another five coming another five I
could take I have this move oh that was
a terrible move that was such a bad move
oh no okay opponent had Knight f3 but
missed it
a knight of three would have like just
been probably a draw it's still
complicated though cuz I'm losing this
or am i I probably am this tricky move
yeah rook takes I have this oh no I
don't I haven't this move maybe a
Knights tied down to the rook
there's rookie seven here yeah
takes it should be just a win but a time
situation move all the way back okay I'm
setting up some trickiness
now this should be pretty simple when
all in the pawn
keep pushing the King back it's
important for the rook to be far away
just so there's no like forking
potential how to do this
eat you I guess like five seconds Wow
let's go
I forgot about my time I got comfortable
so I saw like 18 seconds and I looked
again I saw like five seconds yeah yeah
my appointment had a night of three a
while back and I have three followed by
king g2 and I'm not better victory this
yeah okay
okay it's still in top ten it took a
long time yeah I don't relax too much
Prestage a thanks for subbing thanks
doctored yes I'm for the victory that's
and and I'm the perspective thanks so
much
it makes a tricky and I'm playing again
the first place player
it's a rating all provisional okay I
guess let's play something oh no no I'm
so salty yes what does f6 I guess how do
I justify of 696 I guess f6 is such a
bad move I guess I'll do this garbage I
meant to play you six
I meant to play time lot of make the
banana happy so worse possible move I
think I've actually a five is probably
playable I don't know it's probably up
there with with worst moves you rock
Eric thanks for all your content oh
thanks so much
can you smooth acts 93
okay so the goal is to do this a citizen
Castle not lose tog II welcome back I
will miss the stream you'll always be
with us in an emote form by night well
what to play here
the g7 911 I guess passing by biz that's
nice it's like on Poisson but on pause
on bits okay let's um
yeah let's pre move this I just want a
castle it's actually kind of solid like
Bishop here and I hear like it creates a
safe King it's just really passive
monkey 181 banana monkey 181 love em
Rosen let's go Japan free sack and cry
okay yes all except that whatever at all
this
um what to do d6 I mean each fives
coming it's terrifying
can I take on d4 yes I could take on d4
like d6 maybe it's not that bad like my
bishop will come here I mean this is
still scary but I'll deal with it
[Music]
hmm I'll play Queen a5
okay probably have to take actually I
don't have to take complete look see
AIDS
wanna play b5 rook c4 yeah the night
then I can't take cuz it's pinned to a2
b3 good move I think I'll just take in
Queen and c3 and treacly hey hey hey
Nirvana welcome back yeah if you're just
joining this is a three hour 10 minute
tournament I'm playing the person in
first place except no longer in first
place
tied for first place with variants only
do I beat the first round actually let's
play king f7 this isn't so bad I don't
think I'll put her work on c7 I'm up
some nice time too
I want to play b5 yeah why it's actually
threatening to take here which is kind
of annoying
if I play rook c5 I think it's okay cuz
c4 I have b5 like just in time also
attacking the pawn and it's very
positional like light can win Connect
four but then I'll I'll destroy the
connect four very quickly and these are
our two weaknesses a5 yeah block should
be better here if I don't know if it's
enough to like actually win I'm not sure
what my plan is either it's hard to do
much before okay this could give me some
plan I think I'll just take and rook
rook c8 Oh White's considering that but
yeah now now White has a lot of ponds
and they files half open just shuffle
over
this is actually looking promising as
even some mating potential like mb3 rook
83 meets yeah this rook defends this
rook will try and do damage
each six makes sense you look here want
to swing over
yeah the spawns kind of weak I don't
know if I can defend it because h5i just
take a salt on a central thanks for
subbing can play this movie now and then
I'll I'll just take on each for if here
I'm meet hmm
still some meeting yeah let's play
you're okay too
so I'm threatening me also threatening
to win the rook Oh actually if take
serves very nice to me I don't even win
the Rock Hall I'll meet like this
White's pieces get in the way so let's
force meet I guess there's this move
let's basically force me alright that
was nice
another first-place person I played like
a lot of I played visa and I played
variants only I played this I played all
of all of the people above me I beat
them all but they're still ahead of me
work again let's play London
a lot of provisional players this player
is strong in blitz Bishop f5 is nice to
see 94 it's a nice kind of positional
position although might be three and
queen a three and rook do you want I
can't complain
Oh g5g fives not too scary I don't think
I always have to watch out for this fork
just right that's why Rick d1 will come
very soon the a5 is very sneaky yeah I'm
definitely playing a player stronger
than like 1787 Oh a3 is coming
anyway to do with that
how to do i forgot this idea is actually
quite strong maybe if I can win ce6 in
the end and I would want to take that
doesn't work
hmm okay I should probably take with the
c-pawn I'd want to take with this pawn
but a3 is annoying okay so the plans
Queen e2 f3
aha still a three is but a three I have
F three just in time because there's
still a C three potential for luck a
[Music]
pitch show that's a new name
thanks for the bits okay so the night's
gonna have to move unless black wants to
crazy which probably doesn't work and
then I should decide between like rook
e1 or b3 there's pros and cons b3 closes
things down but rook b1 the file opens
b7 can be a target this makes more sense
especially like having the bishop hair
should be good for white if things open
up a southern theology gifting a sub to
Bugsy thanks so much
okay I'm trying to say focus that's a
move to take it take on a3
I played Bishop h6
hmm
miss page six works here g4 may be a
rookie it might be coming
with g4 kg for ticks ticks
I'm just playing on an intuition here
at some point I do want to throw in this
move and then I mean I think black has
to take otherwise like taking here is
pretty traumatic for that
so it takes takes minus six I'll take
care first let's say Queen eighty-five
Queen I threaten them ideas to win f7
hey intuition bits I'm just realizing
there's Queenie six since online the
Queenie six I can win b7 and then still
get through to f7 Bishop always defends
III g v g5 attacking like Bishop could
be crazy so let's take thank you Eric
for your streams I am always so calm and
had the amazing time when people here
that's my stream chatting with you three
keep up great work and play King's
gambit next game hahaha
I'll see about that thanks so much
Pollock GG heart I'm thinking about a
queen here Bishop here takes takes and
then threatening mate and the Queen and
the problem is um there's Queenie for
the Queenie for there's work out for no
but I hang b1 so g5
of each three-two
what to do
I mean h3 actually kind of looks logical
just defends everything rook takes over
takes eight three it takes me seven
let's go for it it's worth defending the
pawn that way my bishop like okay the
the two weak points are now defended I
want to win b7 there's also some idea
just like tripling up could make some
sense
this idea is still interesting but it
probably doesn't do much like a flat
can't take it I've always played this
move
materialise I'm up upon actually
threatening to win another pawn in to
bishops yeah it's getting messy
let's take so rook e8 I was thinking
about taking an ambitious g5
there's no work a six
take six Bishop g5 pro takes a two Queen
f6
have to go for it again intuition and
there's this idea that Quinn g2 could be
scary actually Siri I was not talking to
you
no quiet I know people here that serious
across the room trying to check the web
for me okay ooh oh this could just end
in a draw unfortunately takes takes all
right let's try let's try this oh wow oh
that's a good move I have to say focus
Queen you two probably
I'm still up upon
yeah the position is kind of fragile
so I'm over defending a pawn to give my
queen mobility
I just want to consolidate I'm bishop
would love to come here it's queen bee
one queen bee one rook c1 but thinking
h2 also mate
oh that was a bad move
I was terrible I should have liked King
G - okay so I'm trying to get my bishop
here I could very easily lose this I
have to prevent the light from coming TV
for right now it's restricted there's
gg5 almost drops my bishop thankfully I
have this ship II hate Bob that's so
close to being trapped but not quite
so each four move maybe
also rugby six move
I could pre-move roughly six okay ideas
of that then that's work fh4 maybe
I want to play e4 actually get the
passed pawn
trying to decide if it makes sense to
trade mission for nights like Bishop d66
tack the pawn
okay the lights tied down thrown a check
opponents gonna try and flag me or I'm
gonna try and flag opponents I don't
know
wanna play this move just attack the
pond
I think I'm winning upon now I'm very
low on time
Bishop restriction night hmm go for this
move
okay I want to play this and then taken
them Bishop e5
[Music]
Chuck this is not good hmm oh this is
really bad
Bishop's actually getting trapped
you can move oh I'm gonna lose this I
was playing for a win - probably should
have repeated earlier what to do never
resigned when you have a rope yeah okay
back to turn those rough what to do yeah
my home played well I'd like the
position it's a danger of bizarre King
okay so I was my first loss for the
tournament but not the end of the world
I think the key to at least winning is
probably to play as many games as
possible like I've only played five
games this player has played almost
double me that's crazy
yeah I could have drawn but I thought
there is some winning potential like I
want a pawn but after I won the pawn
things turned very sour sir play d4
again it hasn't played too much on each
s it looks like Oh plays a lot of rapid
okay this was one of like the main
positions in the London there's a lot of
lot of options for that like both bishop
moves okay this is actually the same the
same line I had the previous game u6 in
the 94 I'll try and learn my lesson from
the previous game be careful this is a 5
move
[Music]
but yeah all of this looks pretty
logical I might play 94 and hold off on
Queen f3
I'll Bishop d6 maybe I'll just take in
94 I'm really just playing against this
pawn we could end up trading actually
I'll play a three kick the night away
like for the e-file probably put the
bishop on b3 yeah it's gonna be pretty
positional I probably want to trade I
know Queen and Knight are usually better
than Queen and Bishop so I might want to
keep like a pair of rooks on the board
yeah my phone's playing like very
solidly
[Music]
it could be difficult to like rock this
position because the deep on so
well-defended
I wouldn't want to play rook e5 at some
point like maybe maybe temporarily sac
upon and try and win it back f4 law just
lost the first round of my tournament
today
losing is learning that's a good
perspective thanks arm our PR rookie
five trying to figure out what to do
here in this move
ef4 seems committal another sub Seinfeld
savant thanks for subbing it's
interesting me
[Music]
yeah every game you play even if it's a
win or a loss or a draw always take away
lessons every game you play should make
you stronger
okay if one's taking a lot of time this
this could be another long game for one
hour into the tournament
it's a three hour tournament so I'm
basing myself at forty five points
trying to speed up the pace okay tape
sticks I get the e-file it's not what I
want but because I just Queen e5 next
also the ideas Queen takes years
so if Knight f6 Queen e5 I just want to
Bishop versus night ending actually
takes takes 97 I win this pawn and then
this fun really okay so the ending
should just be winning my opponent must
be sevens hanging amends
now probably before
gonna bring my king into liking f1 um
before makes sense I'm calculating a 4 B
5 I think the King makes it in time so
there's a line a 4 a three-night C 4
Bishop here and it takes takes and I
just had 2 connected passers ok yeah it
should connected pastors on the outside
hour or even better
do I need my king so here here here
I might need my king
let's start with this move as f7 needs
babysitting well maybe that wasn't the
best decision
go play King f1 king g6 Allah move the
bishop back I create a wall with my my
Bishop and pawn if Knight e3 I probably
play a three yeah hello to people I'm
sorry if I'm missing people saying hi
chick Abuja and dare Daryl duck to real
duck let's play this move I'm trying to
stay as focused as possible for these
games
okay Keaney two would be a plunder play
this move
I mean this move and then I'll lock my
Canyon still controlling these Squared's
yeah a nice beautiful wall
and the bishop works very well against
tonight idea is probably just like
Heaney for if this and I I can walk in
okay let's go 18 points so ovarian
solely lost to me and then berserk win
berserk one like all the following games
that's scary
how this player is winning again that's
also scary yeah that was an interesting
game because I was not better but then
something went wrong once I got Queenie
five and it was nice you want to join
the tournament we share a link in the
chat okay let's play let's play
aggressively
okay we have a Stafford gambit this is
one of the one of the testing lines had
this position many times before
targeting III if Queen g2 I play Queen
g5 so nice H file I'm still down upon
but that's interesting g3
I'm very often all Castle queenside with
g3 so early I might want to play like
rook h3 and then eventually triple up go
after this pawn there's also the idea of
like lifting the rook and just attacking
on the Queen side Queen d2 expected
nothing too special so far actually kind
of slow playing it with f6 I'm just a
useful square for the pawn and the idea
is to very soon do this stuff
then each ii and III will be targets and
take this probably not
in Quincy five maybe
if not afford then I take it because b3i
I'm eight d4 is a move but it's kind of
weakening to e4 ID 4 I would probably
move my queen somewhere and then reroute
my bishop yes I'm talking upon expecting
B 3 or 9 C 3 I'm talking again
like honestly it's not a great position
but there's still a lot of pressure now
I've been able to play most moves pretty
quickly I have a clear plan now listen
this may be a list - and Queen d3
interesting considering this probably
Queen b6 some c5 idea
Oh 94 94 I have this move hmm I should
be winning the pawn preventing 96 -
there's some idea b6h for its kind of
random
okay life is good
like the position was worse for a while
just because of the dubious opening but
now it's it's probably much better
she was Ricky one rookie one I play this
move and if this move I take or no I
don't take their looks defendant rookie
for rookie 7 just preparing this
rook c3b for rook here and then I don't
know what's going on
let's just start with King b7 like very
soon I want to play b4 and somehow trap
the rook it's tricky though play five
you're hitting this rook also hitting
the pawn I couldn't just take the pawn
and then this pawn will be weak
yeah variants only is really rocking it
hmm what did you the smooth
wait a minute ooh I think I blundered
oh that's not good let's try this i
blundered but hopefully time will save
me or this tactic will save me more
tactics tactics are my savior and my
opponent could have taken with night it
could have been very scary ok
hey 4th with ovarian swami lost but
playing again ok trying to get back to
those juicy fives maybe i should be
playing more aggressively i tried to
play aggressively that game but maybe
with whites because someone that wins
were were like very long and this vim
has played so many games like everyone
above me has just played more games than
me but slow and steady I guess yeah if
you're just joining this is a reddit
arena there is a there's someone who's
like who's donating a prize fund there's
a post on reddit oh I'm playing oh I'm
playing first place
I should probably buzzer what's his
reading it's from Greece interesting ok
let's play a Sicilian
so my pawns Napa's irking this is risky
but I'm going for the juicy five points
I'll play a an accelerated dragon I was
taking a long time in the opening so we
have Marazzi mines and I think c6 is not
the mean move but I guess it's playable
include I don't need to include d6 a V
598 d6 makes sense like to play c5 or
creates 25 at some point
Quincy tooth typical the idea of a 95
I'm Queen d2 maybe rook e8 Bishop e6
here
yeah just applying pressure and b3 is
prevented because when I things taking
rook b7
idea of doubling up if I ever be three
then I thought I was gonna have
something like Knight g4 even my g4
there's Bishop d4
not sure what to do I'm just playing a
slow move I want to play 97 but I think
95 would have been strong now 97 I have
to play much quicker I got four have
there's a g4 let some idea of a 5 a 4
as each three as possible each three
maybe I move back
while 95 had taken bishop h3
and trying to get something here and
still equal material
what to do who's playing a strong player
here ok Knights 9 f 6 okay I want to do
this stuff I'm ensuring my Queens not
getting trapped
there's some idea of taking at some
point a Queen d7
[Music]
yeah I don't mind the position so much
it's just times gonna maybe bite me
I'm going for the tech now okay for
Queen h3
I'm just abandon my queenside kick this
one okay Bishop e5 not sure what that
does though
let's play vegetable 5 I'm thinking rook
c8 but then it's my back some Bishop 86
idea now also Queen g4 ideas
if I lose a seven-time queen c1 Bishop
c4 okay maybe a five
want to play this move
maybe f5 f5 is kind of risky but it
looks interesting I 535i take a draw I
don't want to draw it's a bad decision
but I like the position with the
kingside
Bishop e6 Wow
okay so the idea was to play f5 I could
just be terribly weakening
Papa should be six I have bishop no no
no bishop c3 I have to go for this it's
probably a really bad decision
oh this is really bad
I should have taken the draw yeah it's
incredible Bishop Jean one saves white
not to do
yeah I over pushed maybe this move so my
do you have takes in Queen f3
like everything's kind of falling but
I'm down the case we have three things
to cola appreciate that Chuck it's a
risky line for a white to go for but
also for me too Chuck I guess
I have 15 seconds this is really bad
Bishop g2 pleased upon still taking a
long time here and like the position is
actually still interesting but I'm just
down to 14 seconds donuts it's got some
endgame
yeah like we should just take the pond I
don't know why it's thinking so much
just hoping for like some miracle
checkmate
wait draw Oh No
I was expecting play this move
my queening no I'm not quitting
unfortunately oh that's so sad
I resigned that was a weird finish Oh
what did you
I should have taken the draw f5 was a
little bit a little bit over-ambitious
okay so still top ten I've lost two
games yeah buzzer 'king was dangerous
there too
[Music]
still okay we're almost halfway through
yes yeah I'm deserting trying to catch
up hey hey the true salami welcome back
something for four months so not h5 it's
a move I've actually studied the idea is
h6 here g5 and then e 4e for juice it's
a night
oh there's 94
um Bishop Siwon I guess okay this is
kind of weird
we're just disobeying opening principles
I've undeveloped only develops peace but
I was scared of Queen b6 the Queen b6
pressures so many things
Streicher chests thanks for subbing
called variance only is running away
with it the goal is to finish like top
three but it's still far away and so
many players on streaks
and d4 okay so I could take there's also
a before here let's take
9:05
I play Quincy one just undeveloped
everything like where else does the
Queen may be Queen afore was a weird
opening oh it looks like there's
although ma sorry if there is drama in
the chat it's all although month's
faults probably there should be too
Oh what to do
yeah the positions just not that
impressive this will play this move you
just have to play quickly
we're gonna end up trading Queens what
does this move takes takes only 94 I was
gonna try and take advantage of this
night it's kind of an awkward piece
hmm
some g4 move then trade okay
reinforcing my Knights I'm out of I had
a mushroom was it mushroom powder coffee
but now I'm out should have made some
more okay it's an easy position to play
it's still a decent amount of time the
bishop the bishops probably going to
develop to to d7 I'll play rookie one
[Music]
yeah the rooks are I have to obvious
squares to come to
and it's really up to luck like
developing isn't so easy I play rookie
won the night will be hit and I might
have to come back if my comes back I'll
play nights night be three to come to
see five these these two things are
targets
I guess there's an ic693 e5 then Bishop
III and these are the main targets now
your knight and c5 is it combines well
with a bishop coming to f3 like that
even if the bishop comes here I still
can hit it so maybe be 6v6 rook a d1
Bishop f5 way g4
Brook t1 Ashley Bishop f3 just apply a
media pressure it's to prevent
b6v force playable but I think it's
overextending I have lots of bishop yes
I'll just move back
and then there's some idea of gee 495
attacking both palms a p6 is a good move
what to do bishop here
sort of party one we're gonna end up
trading and just leaving the tension
when the time is right I want to play g4
and then try and win the pawn complete
Bishop g5 here and Bishop g5 f6f-5 is
also coming Bishop b5
the idea is to like move this Bishop and
attack the pawn play Bishop d4 even 94
there's a line Bishop c4 takes takes
Bishop c1 hitting the pawn at 596 but
that rook takes d1 Hey
Osborn thanks for something yeah I do
appreciate the new the new subs today
and returning subs I'm trying to say
focus it's a lot of a lot of chess games
to play play it back-to-back what to do
here b3 c for some idea bishop would be
sad then i'm just before
I'm not sure you 3c4 there's Bishop f7
okay
kami thanks for subbing two new subs
yeah I was thinking this but then my
bishop would be a bit awkward
I'm expecting a 5 I was calculating
something f5 and then takes and then
knight c6 and trade it looks pretty
equal I mean I would like to play for a
win as usual some idea night c2 actually
if takes and I play this Bishop e3 94
back I'll win the pawn there's another
idea with Knight seat let's say I 5
night see to the threat is to take and
in take mm Bishop c4 Brook t81 another
said yeah thanks to all the twitch prime
subs parth des I or is it part des out
of the third thanks so much
Bishop b7 play what to play some f3 move
at some point yeah three right away
always play off three
so the pawn is basically pinned to the
night ff5 I was just assuming a 596
which probably works cuz take stakes and
then there's no rikiei and I'll win the
bishop and then win the night and
meanwhile I have two attackers against
the pawn there's a six
if a six I'll play like Bishop a4 move
the bishop back though accepts Bishop a4
there's 93 so a six I'll play Bishop
etholon always play a three always play
Bishop etholon been flying those would
be so proud and yeah black doesn't have
a great way to defend I'm making up the
the time deficit
but it's another game that's kind of
going the full distance I don't know how
the other players are playing so many
games let's just have to be more
aggressive
well I'm going to do with the channel
points I don't know I haven't really
played around with it that much maybe
y'all I'll be open to feedback if people
want to give me suggestions okay so I'm
up a pawn bring the knight that loses a
pawn back or does it it kind of does but
kind of doesn't so the ideas after takes
takes takes I have a knight c5 attacking
the bishop preventing Bishop e7 and
winning this pawn bishop C - I have rook
T to Bishop f5 maybe g4
and how blocks gonna have to take time
here Oh Bishop b1 hmm I played before
defending and preventing a 5 I just want
to win this pawn let's take Oh see
threes hanging move back
it's getting weird takes I trap the
bishop
and when I win this pawn also attacking
the rook okay thing the night I have two
outside passers and should be good
enough
mmm that's nice okay took some work got
the win another game on these
provisional readings scare me over there
I need to berserk to try to work my way
up
Plano 6mm we have a London okay this is
a nice nice variation of the London see
four blocks already four choice here
there's two moves for whites Queen c2 or
queen takes me six and now yeah now I
have the half of a file nice pawns so my
dear would be fine before
it's another positional game but it'll
be a nice positional game
opponents taking a lot of time I've had
this position only dozens of times
before so there are some nuances with
the move order like if I play b5 first
36 or even h6
I think with a ch3 I play h6 don't flag
I've only used ten seconds so far
yeah with the channel points I think the
the best approach is just to hoard them
as much as possible
it's wage six just so you can brag about
having more points than everyone else so
yeah I play each six before II 6z6
sometimes runs in tonight's h4 but II 6
will win Connect four rows and let's go
girl was taken Chris welcome back thanks
for something but for 10 months
yeah I'm trying trying my best here yeah
let's put you six and now b5 on the
horizon also yeah we can we can get some
connect for emotes in the chat it's a
very simple like structure to play
blocks pieces find nice squares this is
a positional idea if I ever plays a3
then there's some maneuver let's start
with this
so I maneuver to play Knight here here
here because I could have considered
taking
yeah should I take goodbye g5 first
don't know let's take
the idea is still to play on Knight b6
to a4 and the King will probably find a
square 97 imagining white we'll try and
go for a 4 so let's say like f 3 9 a 4
on 4 Bishop g6 because Bishop g6 right
away I think typically the goal is just
to leave the tension between the pawns
I never want to take it takes takes keep
the structure I might want to play
Bishop d6 soon those bishops not doing
anything well when will the winter
marathon part to come out on YouTube he
watched all the 12 hours of part 1
yeah I was um I didn't want to put part
2 up too soon because I knew it would
take a while for people to watch all 12
hours
maybe I'll post it tomorrow I do have it
I just need to make a thumb now
but yeah today at least the stream today
I'm reading chat less than than usual
because there's money on the line there
there I think there are money prizes for
the top three I'm still man I have 20
points to make up been playing some some
pretty good players like so far been
having some good games too I think this
game it's easier to reach hack as my
opponent it's like taking so long wait
is a Super Bowl tomorrow yes I didn't
realize that I don't follow football or
as Europeans call it American football
oh the term in command is sharing the
wrong link edit there we go now it
should be sharing the right link so the
idea is after it takes takes be two
would be the target and I'll lift one
ruck and then lift another rook was this
I could take a pawn upon also play e5
check so sneaky I'll play this move
actually
I'm confused now
Oh King yeah if I do this on this check
how to do King see seven mites gonna
have to constantly worry about me too
but I really don't understand how like
anyone can have so many points I guess
it's just playing aggressive like
winning games quickly die I've been
trying to do but it's hard to win games
quickly when the opponent takes so long
okay and yeah I'm getting another like
positional situation it's another game
that could just go the full distance Oh
a five okay
so unfortunately I can't really make
much progress on the queenside so I have
to shift gears to the Kings side and
eventually break either with f6 or some
G pawn move
a couple eg5 here
I was not anticipating to play g5 so
early but the idea is after g3 takes
takes riff gee it's good for the file if
Brooke g1 probably just work aids the
Brooks always tied down to be to trying
to employ there's a principle it's
called the principle of two weaknesses
okay it's tanking repute and it's
basically okay there's one weakness now
I have to find another weakness on the
kingside and then try and spread like
thin Cairo chief for probably
I want to walk my King probably to f5
yeah these are the two weaknesses and
sometimes that's what you need tell you
in a game like one weakness isn't enough
okay so let's walk keep walking
Kirchhoff three looks nice this is
another weakness I five could happen but
then I just take
yeah King f2 could happen
thinking f6 looks kind of wrong but
that's probably wrong what to do
I'm going this way King f2 I'll play
rook g7 because rook g6 94 is kind of
annoying now I am threatening to take it
meanwhile I still want to move my king
up except if I move it up too soon that
each work and me mate so maybe up this
way to the rook back hmm I'm realizing
my knight might want to come to f5 how
do I get there like this probably and
it's funny rook g2 still loses a pawn
because I just moved back and the b2
plant can't be defended can I just play
this
I'll toy around a little bit and then
this move yeah like out a little bit
awkward now
the rook is kind of training because
this works tied down yeah this is very
nice
rook t3 actually no need walk the King
up Oh No let's not pre move it does not
mean to treat vous for a cage three that
could have been really bad man let's
play a this
I mean this sort of game this is my
style of chess just like a very low risk
the whole game slowly build up the
advantage wind stuff now my day is going
well so far been playing a lot of chess
play this move
the f4 okay let's play this first and
then this oh wait I could take on b2 I
think in that line and then 93 okay
three nights
okay now I've lost it like critical
moments to my two losses missed out on
to five points this is crazy variants
only I was winning all the games so I'm
trying to catch up to the person I lost
to that's gonna be really difficult
very closely for its I'm just gonna try
and win without using more than the
minute on my clock okay grand prix time
I should have taken first okay the small
why is black thinking okay I definitely
am either will player based on the
readings
it's another opening I've had many times
[Music]
this is definitely another style of mine
like at least while I play low array the
players don't know what each five each
five was slightly unusual
let's play Queen Queen h4 f5 ideas
Knight g4 in Bishop f6 come for the 95
yeah I think the night might have to
return there's some E 5 ideas also some
idea like Knight Returns f5 takes and
then Bishop g5 looks nice
J Bishop f6 I can play Queen e1 matrix
f5 attack in the night
also f5 is connect four could be two
games with Connect four in a row or all
these g5 emotes this my opponent could
play g5
yeah I guess black bloc's deciding
between these three moves and maybe this
move g5 deserves yellow arrow ok there's
about 621 f5 or Knight g5 or even Queen
g3 like when g3
I'm trying to calculate like very
concretely like some wind like f5
starting with that five makes the most
sense and then like either taking on
each six or 95 even this move
not seeing it
v5 doesn't look right
I look so close so
when ig5 because if the bishop takes and
the darks words are very weak there's
some idea of take enough seven at the
right moment actually King g7 Knight
takes off seven because Knight takes
takes King h8 takes King goes back Rock
g4 that's probably enough can be a nice
move
yeah so I'm unleashing the bishop it's
it's interesting because three different
things can take if King takes I'm a than
one if rook takes light when the night
and if my takes I take I take and eirick
lifts and I I presume that should be
enough yeah black has to take here hey
we have Germany hue basic welcome all
these people using like my most random
commands feel like I have to delete some
of these commands okay I should probably
keep calculating like if my phone is
thinking you're here here black would
have two options if here I could force
this I think the the lines I go for is
um
okay whatever option black plays I just
play rook at for her Brooke maybe you
work here is better I don't know
probably work out for up at the 95 if
this could also throw in the check
yeah maybe workout three actually
also I could I could consider moving my
Jeep on like g4g five and then connect
five and then someday connect six oh
wait a minute
rookie chain is a move hmm I forgot work
H AIDS let's throw in a check first
maybe this move button still 95
yeah this was not my original intention
but it looks okay because now if rook
Chiat I win the night and I'm still
threatening check and check and then
just winning
all these commands I just forgot about
yeah like there are some lines where 95
could have been strong defensive move
like if we're got 495 and I can't access
either of these squares
again yeah this game
this games taking like all my games are
going like about I guess 12 to 15
minutes but at least I'm having
interesting games happy with this night
takes f7 sac
it's just winning right and quit h5
Roach III that's just force meets o or
it's not
or is it rotates g7 I first about Bishop
g7 and takes Bishop h6 looks good enough
actually Bishop e6 immediately 295
defends Oh
[Music]
let's start with this and I'll just
bring another rook in
yeah I should have seen this but I
thinking about taking and still look
straightforward
yeah Brooke f4 everything's stuck for
flak these pieces just can't move I
can't really move Bishop heat so the
black has one idea work f6 which is kind
of annoying but to h4 takes takes okay
dr. tournament let's go I should still
be top ten I think
there I am okay got my five buzzer King
points a lot to catch up on
oh okay bigmouth
I mean variants only is like guaranteed
to win this turn so there's really no
pressure
let's play let's play dragon this move I
have to remember to do okay let's play
d6 okay we're just gonna have a dragon
six
[Music]
yeah we played the first game got the
better of them
95 here looks natural some idea of night
each five to two F for some idea also
Queen b6 rook d8
interesting yeah Rudy one Queen c7 NIDA
for looming g6 - could be useful
yeah it's an interesting configuration
on the kingside because these pieces
look like garbage but the Knights never
get trapped because g4 9 f4 meanwhile
listen before ideas maybe just slow play
efore can be a target later on like a 5
B 4 or Brooke c4 even Brooksie 424 just
trying to identify my resources so rook
T to start with this yeah rook d7 could
be slightly annoying that in work c7
and I ate too
what to do
rook here
of attacking and defending my house he's
moves but I don't think they do too much
that's a good sign
keep applying pressure
yeah b3 is a good move or on ctrader can
move
yes I have to take leave this first
tacking be - it's my new target because
e4 is defendant
I should probably play 9f 494 Bishop g3
oh wow was this rook d7 subtract this
one that four makes sense
I could be blundering rook t7 here
this is very dangerous 26 was another
move
this is very very dangerous oh I have
rook c7 okay rook c7 keeps me safe
expecting rookie AIDS
doesn't work
let's try this in Queen b6 hitting b2 it
takes I take with a pawn bishop d4
pressure against f2
each for tweaking g7 Quincy five
fellas okay actually this was looking
okay Brooke Davis before I just take
with rook probably want to shuffle my
rook to h8 the reverse work lift
also taking is maybe possible takes
takes right
this looks working
rook takes b2 and then the night it's
left undefended and I'll have Queen and
four verse Queen into expecting Queen up
three oh there's a 91 there's a 91 but
then a 92 as well I just wondered that's
six maybe
we haven't the smooth others just the
Strasse I want to draw ticks ticks
or does it draw
yeah kind of drawers you'll see if like
goes for it yeah it's just a drama
ah I thought I was winning but I'd
forgot about 92 I mean I could have
played on with f6 I think yeah it was
probably best to draw though I have
anything my King f8 is somehow winning
Wow I'll have 6 Queen takes c6 yeah a
difficult game good game
Toth tournaments
so variants only only lost twice once to
me and once here then first draw
yeah King f8 is like impossible to find
well least I didn't lose
I don't think I'm gonna play e4 f5 they
find at least if I'm black happy to play
against it
okay waiting for a game pull myself
together I mean overall I think I've
been performing better than my rating
got gained rating points
it's a tough tournament yeah the problem
with a dry I do lose my street let's
play E for hey okay nice to see let's
play play hillbilly
this is probably dubious it's probably
really dubious get opponent didn't want
the free pawn this is actually looking
fine now
lady three I can trade yeah I clean I
teach three so I want to open file I
want to play this move also long takes
which I would have been happy yeah
overall this is like very comfortable
position got for coming maybe all when
connect for again f5
let's take take with a rucker night i'll
take with the the rook just preparing
the double-up 9f5 yeah all the pieces
are gonna participate I could take even
I could take kind of five yeah intuition
time
well maybe Knight h5 was slightly
stronger but this should be good enough
I should have played Mary trife what to
do
there's no way box defending this
there's no way I'll take with the rook
and then I'll bring my knight in it
looks kind of slow but like what does
black do like Knights the other night
just comes in
and yet if that goes for this and or if
black goes for that I have this proof
this month actually Queen Daisy 4 is
probably the best try hoping that I pre
move Queen takes h7 but it's not
happening so I just need more games like
that where it's like just a quick win
and what that took less than five
minutes that's probably most of like
first places games scary player let's
preserve yeah I'm going for broke I'm
gonna play Stafford okay no Stafford we
have a four Knights not the most
exciting opening so this player place
mostly blitz what does be three I could
play a Halloween Halloween time okay
unexpected Halloween okay three so
random
I don't know if b3 makes a difference
also what's the move here probably this
b3 actually weakens the rook in some
cases it's White's giving back the piece
yeah I should probably take it yeah b3
is actually useful Wow now it was
probably a good decision
my opponents I'm gonna go for Queen d7
castling queenside probably Bishop g4
okay let's get the bishop pair realizing
this is gonna be pretty uncomfortable
but what to do let some Queen h4 move at
some points
Queen g5 as now it doesn't make much
sense for me to Castle queenside so I'm
gonna try and Castle kingside and we're
both gonna try and attack like we're
both kind of set up well to attack kind
of five and neither five can be really
annoying play this move but then they
each five Wow
actually there's a small is there a
small trick maybe there's not
I'm thinking my king might be safe this
97 weirdly enough I just hugged by its
own pieces
okay I'm being extra careful here you're
here
not sure what lights accomplishing with
this move the only thing that changed is
now the night can't come to h5 which was
what I was most scared about if you want
to cheer don't type a space between
cheer and 500 Oh
rookie 5 couldn't move but I have this
move or this move free pawn this is so
risky I could just lose really quickly
oh this is so terrifying I could just
also be up up on this we'll find out
very soon you can Bishop f6 I think
someone earlier was asking why f6 f6 is
terrible because it weekends too much
even though it blocks a bishop I still
have calcium rights on both sides
what are my chances of catching up I
mean two more berserk wins Allah
I'll have 47 points I'll be in maybe
fourth place I have five it's terrifying
got it
hey hey Stephen from Montreal thanks for
figuring that out
I played about six yeah I just have to
pray that I'm not getting smashed think
it's okay though
oh there's rookie - but rookie - Queen
g5 even rookie - I could take can then
take hey dr. Lowe no thanks for
something for seven months yeah I'm
getting slightly fatigued still over
half hour left
okay opponents going all-in so I could
take I have to take no reason to think
Richie Yates age six expected and then
just castling queenside blocks probably
doing ok here
I could maybe win see to who was this
move I forgot about that move I could
play this move I'm not dead yet the goal
is to play this in this I'm also
preventing working one yeah my King
actually might go to d7 yeah I like King
d7 here makes a lot of sense you rookie
one expected in g6 so pawns are equal we
both have six plans but I'm not the
exchange
I might want to play rook AE and then e
v because the bishop is basically pinned
to the G to pawn through some sort of
x-ray vision
that's interesting let's still go for
this
now he 5 you have a bishop still pinned
the goal is to play rookie sex a while
it is this
interesting
throwing some check i mean queen g6
looks solid and then d4 even this move i
don't care about this pawn
I'm debating which pond to move like a
five or d4 I think d4 makes probably the
most sense because then either light
blockades and the brook is passive or I
just start pushing the queen is a 6 d 4
and D 3
okay now Queen defends a6 play d4
there's a sneaky idea to play this and
that takes because again the bishop
would be pinned oh that sneaky from
white and I scared
I don't think I'm too scared this you're
here I always have ways to defend in
Queen f5 and then Queen e6 even queen
are five kings c6 other than rook here
interesting
I want to put the King back I'm not
getting needed right looks okay there's
some crazy Bishop effects but then just
queen c6 or just takes even
a weird position
ooh forgot about that
what to do
ah what to do that's probably a really
bad move yeah this is gonna this is not
gonna be easy to win now
Napoleon could have taken the rook and
then taking on e6 I think that was best
she now white still has some issues to
solve h7
okay so I defend h7 thanks for the bits
oh no I just wanted a rook what to do
let's play oh this is so bad
no I resigned that was really bad
Oh what to do i crumbled there
the fatigue got to me ah to do yeah I'm
gonna try and finish decently strong now
the position was so good could open up
which died someone suggesting record
sets I mean the bishop was always
defending me for it was just a bad move
I should just push yeah okay
that's life I've only had three lawsuits
like not the worst Rizal ever but when
you when you see like this score it's
that's crazy
did your sub work yeah it shows if you
have like a the chest piece next to your
name and your subbed you can hover over
it I played this upon previously that
was a London game from earlier a 6 ok
let's play Sicilian ok a 5 this is
actually a kind of a fun line connect
for so early if it takes and I can take
here there's some nice pin
no variance only is not Nakamura because
I have won the first game and I also
have a good position the second game we
played
yeah I'm just maintaining the pin I
might play Knight g5 actually take with
enlightens I guess there is some sort of
I don't want to say luck
but if opponents are busy arcing back
and then he'll just get more more games
than okay queen g4
well played Bishop h6 and probably
Castle queenside also attacking a6
or you've been watching YouTube avidly
nice good to hear I didn't post a
youtube video today because I'm
streaming I didn't want to give people
too many choices let's play this but
I'll host again tomorrow you just call
me Hanson called be my my mother the
other last name with other Eric what to
do position looks really good
I could Castle queenside I could get the
bishop air
gasps and queenside first leaving
tension gonna make it sharp I have some
ideas just pushing eh pawn I'm searching
for tactics but I'm not seeing like that
much
the Knights gonna come to f5 I take
okay so challenging the rook I'm
actually threatening maybe this but
maybe not I don't know and now that five
is expected but then I can take the pawn
maybe because here it takes takes takes
it's a fork it takes here I can take and
unleash the rook to Knight c5 work on
move fifteen maybe possibly perhaps yeah
it probably Bo CAD I got around to
winning with c5 pawn it's a big mess
like the things are staring each other a
lot to think about here
but I think everything's under control
but yeah it's still a mess can I just
take a look and then what did you night
see five that's a fork also discovered
attack and if this I I can do another
Fork Wow in queen g4 I just trade yeah
okay that was nice performance reading
yeah my performance rating is slightly
higher than my current rating oh that
was someone who I lost to previously so
I got revenge okay
yeah rest of the games I'm buzzer King
I'll try and finish off in some style
yeah variance only is just crushing it
it's so rookie 2 rookies amazing move
Wow this takes takes uh the Queen's
unleashed and rook teaches a threat I
probably have to study like these games
and see how how they were winning so
quickly it's so bad so sad that name
gives me confidence and happiness ok
let's play d5 if this I do this if this
I do this the side you love
I feel like this could be another long
game like my opponent might use up all
the time and then the tournament's over
okay I'm gonna try and play a Cambridge
Springs but this in this yeah we're
following following mainline Quinn a
five it's a pin Queen b3 okay applying
pressure don't think I've seen Queen b3
before trying to think it might be
playable
I just want to apply more pressure okay
here so there's a nice trap of just
winning a piece and now yeah it's a
double attack this is one of the main
ideas of Cambridge Springs to exploit g5
with and I than the Queen
it's a nice opening if you want to like
try and trap someone against the like if
they're at Queen's Gambit player chess
we do things for the hosts shout out to
the weep they use a weed command yes I'm
just up a piece I'll see if the opponent
wants to resign the ponents username
kind of reflects this position for
whites especially after this
there was no chiii but Tom okay
got some Tournament points
not sure how many more games I'll be
able to fit in I think I want to chase
at least get to fourth place that would
be the main goal for this game g6 was
pointless
trying to remember what to do here like
Bishop e2 I don't know I got five at
some points maybe here there's a game I
think it's between hammer and xud or
hammer played like a beautifully as
White's had the structure to Bishop g3
some h4 idea yeah this structure is like
it was all intended with this sort of
Knight f5 move yeah let's go for each
for even the g5 or queen d3 or Queen d2
I'm so many choices match for is very
tempting here
I think Oh Castle I'm allowing this and
I'll take with pawn it's kind of risky
Eric come to Ukraine we have borscht
that is tempting look but the borscht
makes it even more tempting okay let's
play this move Queenie for up I have
queen up for I just lost a pawn for
nothing man I I got distracted by the
borscht could use some borscht right now
okay opponent didn't take it
so let's play what to play g5 yeah g5
capone's just trying to flag me let me
play f6 take sticks hmm I'll start with
this because there are some g6 ideas too
like a v g6
[Music]
and this should all be okay
rookie for coming maybe rookie one we
trade I want to take my time here but
it's not much time to to use
and start with this
thinking about sacking a queen at some
point it's interesting I do like my
chances while pond takes so now work you
wanna
you just smooth this is nice I prevent
queen g4 also I prevent rookie 4 I just
want to do this this and this
this could be the last game which comes
for the tournament and that tournament
flew by Wow variants won't leave that's
insane
100 points yeah I guess I'm happy to
finish like top ten of the top
tournaments yeah my team will be extra
safe
[Music]
you'll see five I just have to find a
good square for my queen
let's take now I'll see five I just do
this I think looks like there's Queen e1
so c5 I could play this just have the
gun mmm tricky move
I mean King b2 is probably the safest
option
Oh was king b2 team b2 is a blunder but
opponents actually now I don't know
what's going on opponent miss rook e1
which I think just one on the spot cuz
Queen e1 I'm so focused on myself mating
I forgot my opponent is trying to make
me I just take I'm taking doesn't work
because we're take C - Quinn 8 - mm-hmm
that's getting sharp have to play this
month
[Music]
Wow I see four triple pawns now it's so
sad if I don't win this play this move
maybe
try this yeah I'm so close to meeting
but I'm not meeting well I have one
trick
maybe the opponent will fall for it
no this is so risky I'm trying to win c5
interesting
my phone's gonna try and beat me maybe
which is my only chance to win wool
jackets
hey uh what was expecting the King eh -
I won that those nice I think that was
my only hope was to like run my time
down and my point was just playing too
quickly
Wow I thought my point was gonna try to
go for lucky five and I was gonna play
g6 okay time for one more game what a
game
I'm happy to end with that one I think
I've done that once before when the
opponent like has a clear repetition and
you run your time down you provoke them
to try and win and then they mess up
it's a very risky approach though man
okay so I'm gonna finish around this
place covariance only has posed a nice
number nobody expects the Spanish bid
that was the noise ending noise that's
noise okay final game
also Spanish bits like Spanish the
opening or Spain Spanish the language no
hablo mucho ha spaniel
pero hablo poca d for free pond maybe d3
was intended its develop pack hack 21
thanks for subbing this is kind of fancy
just want to attack I'll play this first
I just blunder Queen f3 I may have just
wondered but maybe not Oh white just
blundered let's take care of first
oh there's a Spanish Inquisition joke I
need to study my history
ok I'm winning upon um let's attack the
high plundered Knight f3 opponent missed
it though so many blunders let's play
this move I have three would have
attacked and attacked I would have lost
a bishop come on play Bishop d5 this
feels like a marshall gambit except I'm
the one up upon I don't want to trade
Queens oh there's a chat that Queenie
forum rook rook e8 it kind of works kind
of doesn't work yeah rook e8 doesn't
work actually
opponent wants to draw oh I just wanna
wait I keep hanging a bishop why do I
keep hanging a bishop so many plungers
this game this is such a it's such a bad
game okay but somehow I'm not telling
any material I feel like I've wondered
at least three times this game always
playoff six each five looks nice okay I
might see two incoming
wait I don't want optical or bishops or
do I maybe I do yeah
we have an office of Clare Bishop ending
but my King's so powerful it should be
winning somehow
no draw
this is a tricky move
there
I deal with c5 is to prevent the bishop
from accessing a3 now I can play pawn a3
and then do this stuff maybe it might
just not work but I'm trying
yeah c6 was a better another option if
you're a white there it's still not easy
to win this maybe it is easy because I
can I can push
but will I win before the trim in time
runs out yes just in time
okay back to tournament hey I finished
in fourth good tournament everyone
congratulations
variance only for crushing it's trick or
treat and seconds Rose Zack and third
the I lost I lost her Rosa I don't think
I played trick or treats I did beat
variance only in the first game they
came back strong yeah that was a fun
tournament thanks to the redditor who is
this someone there's a reddit post which
maybe I can share
here's a initial reddit post so there
was um these were the prizes sadly I
finished in fourth so I missed out but
yeah thanks to chess subreddit for
putting this together and I think I
don't know the username of the person
who who started it but but thanks it was
fun had 677 players so um yeah thanks
everyone for for tuning in a lot of
people here I think's John for watching
ever come to Montreal I was in Montreal
in August's for tournaments would love
to come back but probably not in the
wintertime maybe in the summer so if I'm
not mistaken the one the only been
Feingold is doing a 12 hour stream today
so I think I should send a rate over the
one bangle I'll probably put this on
YouTube YouTube people thanks for
watching I'll leave a link to the reddit
post probably be sure to LIKE and
subscribe and also brace yourself for
more YouTube content I have a lot of
stuff in the pipeline I didn't post
today but I'll be posting a lots in the
coming week so yeah I don't exactly know
what that is doing but looks like chess
some form of chess